greetings from podcast Ville the church
is brought to you by Fuji sports.com if
you're looking for a gig if you're
looking for shin guards if you're
looking for boxing gloves a mouthpiece
whatever the [ __ ] you're looking for
Fuji's been there since day one they
survived the bomb you don't say anything
[ __ ] around me I'm a big fat [ __ ] I
go to jujitsu a tug they pull that
[ __ ] Fuji jeez a tremendous go to
Fuji sports.com right now in press in
charge BAM get 10% off sent right to the
[ __ ] Casa you don't have to leave the
house the Japanese guy shows up number
two
you know me dawg I always come up with
something new revolutionary for you you
ready for this one solo Jitsu calm
these are those playing cards that
happen a kippah escapes on and rollovers
and what you do is you play by yourself
you're the hotel room and you flip the
card and you do 22 hip escapes we're in
a [ __ ] of course whatever the [ __ ] it
calls for you do a push-up whatever and
at least you get entertained by yourself
go to solo Jitsu calm and tell them I
sentient take a look alright kick this
[ __ ] melee what's happened mr. Garcia
how you doing man you know I just forgot
I even had that you know that is no I
don't I was sitting there trying to
figure out who's famous Hollywood
Henderson okay yeah this [ __ ]
was the guy that invented cocaine like
he oh my god he [ __ ] took it to the
next level like in the NFL well yeah on
that Dolphins team he was on the Cowboys
he was a linebacker around the Cowboys
what's that when they did an article on
him in 1980 in Playboy mm-hmm that was
one of the best articles I've ever read
in my life and then Serge Ortega a guy
from the church found the Playboy had a
flea market and sent it to me and next
time I'll have it here for you it just
the first paragraph yeah I was a rookie
it was 180 degrees and that was in
Thousand Oaks just that that was comin
yeah in Oxnard it's like they're still
up there they just started again is so
he goes a $20 a half a grandpa coca
Nathan's acid I mean that's how the
paragraphs something just crazy you know
and then he goes on to go to Dallas and
how he would come back to LA and hang
out at the Comedy Store with Richard
Pryor and the Pointer Sisters and they
would [ __ ] freebase cocaine and him
anyone nuts but
against the doubt up against the Denver
Broncos in the playoffs right before you
went to play the Broncos yeah a can of
orange Krush and he [ __ ] crushed it
because I'm a [ __ ] you [ __ ] up
and then the Super Bowl he is deceptive
the ball and [ __ ] scored a touchdown
so he was badass
yeah but he's snorting blow with three
hands this is the seventies nobody knows
what to do with this [ __ ] the NFL's
got him the ambient this guy Marvin bad
news Barnes they threw him out of the
game once he came out with a 45 wanted
to shoot the ref you know this is when
they were still [ __ ] crazy
back when sports were fun [ __ ] crazy
and this [ __ ] nut is a great
linebacker you know when he's a great
linebacker his drug use is kind of
coming out little by little and then one
day when they had the old coach Tom
Landry that real old yeah with the
Hatcher they will lose on national TV
and this [ __ ]
got a towel from his Drew Pearson and a
towel company and he put the cow company
in front of his dick like it was it
wasn't a sexual anything yeah that's how
you put your thousand of your
quarterback and he went like this with
the towel number one the next day Tom
Landry fired him like fired him knowing
he was a coke fiend hear him if you
watch the footage today whereas they're
going into the locker rooms after a game
of people going yeah yeah he's like
yelling party where's the Colombians at
in all this [ __ ] this is night they're
not ready for this [ __ ] guess who picks
him up who do you think - what team
picks him up I don't know Miami Dolphins
okay perfect
he goes to Miami I don't even know I
don't even know if he got the play I
don't [ __ ] remember but he's done in
maybe a week and Pat like he got caught
for smoking pot so now they can't find
his m.i.a and they send the big guy from
the Oakland Raiders that counted the guy
that Wow BAM oh no every year he has
like his top dozen football players
Madden ok yeah mad they found they said
Madden interviewed and mads like we're
here to disco in Miami in the afternoon
and [ __ ] Hollywood's like so what I
smoked the joint where the store is and
that was the end that's it anyone ought
to deep end
but then he found Christ and then he won
the lottery in Texas with like 8 million
dollars like the lotto I don't know if
he's back on that what a life
yeah well now wouldn't you get that
poster the a friend of mine named Bob
Linkous knew I was a fan of his like his
legendary yeah and sent me this poster I
think he sent me a poster he sent me two
great books on him you know there was
just [ __ ] have enough didn't care that
he was doing coke they put it right
though this [ __ ] me that's why just
ring it there's a 7-up post like I don't
even saw that before yeah America's
turning up seven oh yeah what's up dawg
how you doing fresh fresh I like that
new concept yep so you'd have this show
they don't bother you so you'll never go
back the network cover I don't know man
it's gonna be tough yeah this new one
that yeah they just let you do what you
want which is cool
which is cool some but if it sucks then
it's all on you but now it's it's a it's
been a good ride with this one
I didn't network show about two years
ago I was only there for two days didn't
bother me at all I felt bad for the
series regulars because it was CBS yeah
and then we'll get the [ __ ] door
Church yeah they'll have a lot of
thoughts I was sitting there and I mean
the writers and then some guy is making
faces and then the director would tell
him no when there was just fall and I'm
watching this calm why does this even
have to happen for us to make a dollar
you know and something the writers
wanted something to work but the network
didn't and I'm sitting on what the [ __ ]
and it was a popular show it got
cancelled that really don't matter I
mean at the time but it's so it's hard
you know drama it's hard enough to do
one of those things every week without
you know without having to be at war at
the same time you know and protecting
stuff and what-have-you but there's a
lot of places now I think where they've
been a little more hands-off although
you do you think would you listen
they're very hands-off I mean they did
nobody bothered me on that [ __ ] sell
it all Maron was I am oh yeah everyone
nobody shows up yeah you know when you
get into and I'll say it I'm 55 years
old I think the worst I ever worked for
was Fox yeah they they just broke me
they really broke me earlier I shot five
pilots for them they just probably yeah
they just I couldn't CBS has always been
cool with me and BC cool like a
[ __ ] you know yeah and everybody
changes his clothes like Fox's always
wouldn't been the one that's always
gotten on my nerve every time I do a
show for Fox there's a [ __ ] by the way
yeah like I'm in a trailer in a bathroom
or there's always [ __ ] something
inside the Medibank it would show there
was always something you know like there
was always something with Fox that
didn't have what anybody else huh
they're the only ones that's it
CBS has been cool but you know when you
get to the set when you do well I did
spider-man 2 you know you get people
that open the door fee yeah they pay
them scale open the [ __ ] door fee and
then you turn around do $100 and a movie
where ain't don't be doing dick for you
you know Joey we're also gonna need you
to open the door yeah you got open the
door you got to put your own broken I
tell you have to bring your own clothes
you know those I've done a thousand
hundred holiday movies we get like wow I
could handle this yeah run the cuckoo
for us I mean you know spider-man people
would tell you watch that cord yeah baby
the fried a lobster tails on the grill
come on and all those people like eat
the salads I've taken lobster tails to
go yeah I was stealing lobster tails I
had more lobster tails in the room the
Red Lobster I was [ __ ] you think I'm
kidding you they had a grill they had a
20-foot grill with four guys cooking
[ __ ] lobsters on Friday that's fine
it's a different world now you could
they had the gallons of pob uh-huh ninth
in 2003 it was five hours for a little
bottle of pop it was like 30 for a tank
I would go to spider-man 2 and first for
breakfast I would pour some and I had a
duffel bag
best damn sports show don't beg right
there Sony where we shot there yeah I
put the whole gallon of palm in the
[ __ ] bag and take it right through
the 30 hours [ __ ] you got a squirrel
away and then I smoked open the
greenroom for Sony has a back section
that nobody knows it's like a little
hole
and they look like little batteries and
they put us back there for the overflow
they were out of trailers and I love
that that a TV in it had a phone you
make long-distance calls this is 2003
cell phones still banged you out from
the middle of their life [ __ ] okay
you're catching up
oh I'm calling Europe you've ever saying
I'm making calls but every morning I get
there and I'd be lazy I got so lazy on
spider-man to lie we just smoke dope in
the barracks and then I would pop my
head up let's see the costume lady
pushing the top the Wardrobe in and
right behind there I'd see Sam Raimi and
right before Sam Raimi would hit the
building I don't run out of the building
and grab Sam I'm sure mr. Raimey I don't
mean to Bobbie something keep smoking
marijuana I'm a Christian it has to stop
it's a good move and then go back and
drink your palm oh did you see what the
budget was for that that's why the bed
yeah
do you wonder million yeah they would
throw away money for no reason like they
would those movies like that a [ __ ]
grave once they get that big hit I guess
then oh my god it made them 783 so oh
yeah they they drop to to make a ton of
dough the guy won an Academy Award for
the set designer for he won the Academy
Award for Star Wars I mean that movie
was no shortage of dumb
yeah the fan they had to keep you warm
because it was all this when we shot
that dog they had a [ __ ] fan that I'm
not kidding you had to be okay you know
what he was on the train he was stuck to
the train yeah that was a fan blowing at
him this fan was like a [ __ ] airplane
engine oh yeah you get out of the way
[ __ ] things go flying and [ __ ] you
know it was just great when you work on
a movie like that it spoils you you know
I had a couple of like I had like taxi
and you know these are okay yeah and
then when everything hit the fan in the
hundred our movie started coming up and
you get man they got like apple a jar of
peanut butter with like a [ __ ] fork
in it and you know like I miss my tea
yeah there's like three half a doughnut
yes by the man had walls of food yeah
like well I'm not kidding walls of fruit
and [ __ ] coke
and never mind the longest sure we were
in Santa Fe I understand that hired
these women to just carry trays like
this like cigarette girls yeah and they
would have smoothies and proteins like a
cocktail party it was walking around we
had umbrella girls they went to a strip
club in Albuquerque and got umbrella
girls along a yard and a half a day that
so you wouldn't get a suntan so you
would look the way we worship we were
shooting Earl once on Woodley and it was
hot as hell and we had a PA with an
umbrella over Jaime Pressly and somebody
she's you know the PA styling her around
a little bit making sure she doesn't get
all burnt up and somebody drives by and
yells at us yell something like get the
[ __ ] out of the road or something and
Presley starts chasing down this car and
she runs about 200 yards chasing the car
and the PA is running right next door
with the umbrella
but funniest looking thing you know the
P is like I'm gonna get a fire - exactly
the Sun hits her I'm next so he just
kept right there with her kept her in
the shade the whole time how [ __ ]
crazy is our business like I was I
worked in post so I didn't really get a
ton of it but I had the guy who was the
doctor and like dr. Cox and scrubs come
in and he probably didn't say anything
but the the my boss went on to everyone
that dan said don't look him in the eyes
when he comes here I'm cereal I don't
don't look him in the eyes
no no who sets with okay the first set
was in 2001 during when The Sopranos was
first very very hot and I'll tell the
story he's a great guy I think he was
always cool to me ah politically
incorrect when you get on the set they
tell you come here for a second
don't touch him and don't make eye
contact yeah and then we you know and
now when I see him he's a gentleman
yeah he'll try to fight who was it
whatever his name is Bill Maher okay oh
[ __ ] funniest thing I ever heard with
Bill Maher was when I first moved here
Doug Stanton went to his birthday party
yeah cuz he even hang at The Improv and
stuff and you know he's like so Doug
Stanhope picked up some chicken [ __ ]
on his bed at the party
he found out about it so Bill Maher
called his management and The Improv and
The Improv ik duck stamp a private
apology letter apologize first year the
first time I saw Doug Stanhope was so it
was it was a long time ago and it was
for a showcase for a network showcase
and it was I was like a staff writer on
a show and somebody said hey do you want
to go to this thing and I said yeah I'll
go to it and everybody was getting up
there so this must have been like 90 a
six seven something around there yeah a
trophy and so and he gets up and
everybody's just trying to be on their
P's and Q's it's all the networks are
there whatever he got up there and just
didn't give a [ __ ] and just went nuts
and was hysterical
nobody everybody's looking at each other
going this is a funniest guy nobody knew
what what they would do with him so that
was that but good Lord was he funny
David speaking of funny you see our Boyd
made the [ __ ] cover of Rolling Stone
who we love Walker no he didn't really
seriously pull it out that's amazing
that's amazing oh good for him yes
that's the folding days
that's hilarious it's a once you hit the
cover of [ __ ] unless somebody made it
up somebody just made up a fake cover
how is that well what's the chance of
that about 95% let's see I mean I hope
he did I hope he did here's a guy that
they wouldn't sell his albums and came
on if he pulled on the out like that was
when I went and saw him live and you did
you all go for him
that was a crazy night that was crazy I
was standing next to job Ron Jeremy the
whole time I think we deserves it but I
think you might have had at one time I
go home at night I just I'm lonely doing
it like those [ __ ] two broads you go
to bed at 9:30 they know what happens
after 9:30 my house it's in circus time
I see the smoke dope I eat myself too
you know I'm saying
I found a bag of expired edible two
years old they were so [ __ ] strong
and so good with the Weight Watchers I
gained four pounds like the lady said
what happened to you you was so great
do they give you points for the edibles
do they tell you this started that's a
60 point a 60 calories is one point okay
so I always you know I'm sorry I gonna
put down on the chart edible there's no
G but you are my [ __ ] yeah it's not on
there no I can't go to Weight Watchers
and put cheap at you let's try it let's
see yeah maybe you know what these days
I'm sure we'll be surprised though yeah
they might have got with the program
food let's see cheap mature she chew dad
not seven points craft pizza cheese of
macaroni
[ __ ] that that's cuz it knows what
that's what you're gonna eat after you
eat the cheap would you yeah no no no no
no this 60 the point the the star is a
debt were also dead done did the dead
done you'll never see a star again no
Aniki rest in peace okay what they just
stopped making them are the government
cut them down to a hundred okay the lady
wanted to give me something the other
day the one I do want to give me some of
the other day that I think I've put Lee
through a lot to last six years I love
him very much and he's my little brother
and I torment them I gave Marilyn like
didn't give me heroin yes I do
I always tell hungover pissed us cuz you
never know what say oh hey gave me a
bottle of THC liquid that was a thousand
milligrams because you know we could
take another syringe when I saw the
syringe for two minutes ago I'm gonna
bring it just to petrify away I just
yeah but I just chase him around I think
he won't come back from it like he'll
never come back from me coming in here
with a bottle we go into the therapist
and tower on your French oh he can give
you a shot he doesn't no no no no this
wasn't even a needle of it this is just
the thing that you just take the water
in my mouth it's very white it was for
white peacock you got you to be you know
like oh my God look at this to take it
and you put it under your tongue
you know like now we have a spray
there's a spray that you could thousand
milligrams when he [ __ ] milligrams
our spray that's insane but they cut it
down because as of July 1st the law
changed again so there's no edibles over
a hundred no more so those Chiba choose
or the last now I gotta eat ten of those
together I don't want to do it I don't
want to do it that's too many points did
he try the the dropper cuz if you tried
the dropper we I'm not bringing the drop
because I don't think you'll come back
when I saw the dropper it gave me goose
bumps looking out for and if it gave me
a scared Joey I don't think you you know
what I don't think you come I think you
sit here that might do the dropper and
the next day
it'd be like Marlon Brando in Apocalypse
Now the letter he wrote his wife saw the
house saw the dog I'm never coming back
[Laughter]
maybe right if it scares you I'm not
gonna argue with you
yeah I was like you know Lee's had
enough in this life funny because nobody
anymore like he knew about it and I was
very surprised we were talking about
matters I grew up in a generation and
daughters uh-huh I spoke about it this
week and lot of states that I grew up in
a time that that light in New York you
know when you press the light and it
tells you like 14 uh-huh
there was a time the light didn't tell
you that really just yeah it just went
to yellow and then [ __ ] rent yeah but
junkies would be at the light waiting
across the street and they would not at
the light and then they would like go
into the whole wing oh my god they would
go down on one knee and then you get up
I mean I grew up with a generation and
others and I was telling him that one
time a guy nodded up we got me this
Jersey City was where you got methadone
uh-huh so when we get on the bus to go
to high school we get on the bus with
mothers that took the bus like if you
took methadone they give me like a free
bus pass yeah
yeah last week you gave blood and they
gave you a file of your certificate yeah
because he to a cookie and the soda they
gave you file out it's the same thing
when you go get the methadone if you
went down there they give me like a bus
pass and something else and this guy was
our methadone sitting on the bus already
done and he had a newspaper open it was
open and he was drooling and the drool
was connected from his lip to the paper
Greg Garcia there was just a big circle
and this [ __ ] was him you know
how much desire yeah butt heads popping
all around he wouldn't wake up and
what's wrong and those days would shoot
spitballs at you like we got on that bus
and he were on heroin we would torment
you me and my boys would turn mention
these are last five minutes of happiness
the whole way we'd spent for spitballs
at you and [ __ ] I go I got this and I
blew a fart like one little yoo-hoo cuz
in those days I used to always have a
buttered roll and a usual for breakfast
and that goes right to your [ __ ]
there's no cereal as though the only
Jersey it's a butter all over you who
just bread and you he'll never forget
that blue a fart and this guy was out I
feels like this this is exactly what his
eyes did Greg guy seems like this one he
looked around he's like man what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you guys they got
that shot like pulp fiction that they
give to people in there when they're too
too high on heroin either and they're
going they run out of that shot you
could probably bottle your farts what do
you mean
bottle your farts get it to the the
paramedics do the whole smelling salt
industries exactly it's so [ __ ] funny
I have a friend who was a junkie dear
friend we still talk every days my
brother he's my brother I'm known as I
was and he went through a rough period
and whenever they would so when he was
my roommate he was on heroin I was just
starting Tommy in New York and his job
was every Thursday he went through the
park that move a few rocks and they give
him $140 and food stamps and he'd go to
the city and Kretz rather than for
heroin you know
you've been trading for cash just direct
your heroin directly for the food and
then give him a bus pass but I wait to
get on the heroin I clipped the bus pass
every Thursday I'd come cuz I used to
work in the city so for me to go until
the city my friend's father drove the
bus but even if I had to be at work at
ten I was so poor that I would have to
get up at 6 o'clock bus because he would
let me out for free uh-huh
now I could sleep late so I would clip
his bus pass then he'd get high on
heroin he look at me goes I know you
stole my bus pass a [ __ ] I used to call
the pin cushion at the time he was my
roommate and he would get he would go
clean from Sunday to Thursday and then
he'd pick up ten hundred and forty
dollars I didn't get like a grandma call
and whatever you could and was he sick
from Sunday to Thursday he would sleep
but he was yellow stripes Lee's at me I
call me a loser and tell me I'll never
be atomic and I loved them I know he
what he was going through someone's time
that I might give him ten bucks and tell
him to go fix his [ __ ] huh
but once Thursday came he would go into
his grandmother's room and start [ __ ]
blasting and I mean when you went into
that room Sunday Greg Garcia there was
blood on the walls you thought Sharon
tainted kind of killed from him missing
the horn like and he would have to spend
this whole Monday wiping down the walls
I mean he was losing a gallon of blood
every [ __ ] weekend in the Lord
so me and my buddies used to call him
the pin cushion we'd see him walking
back over the bridge and we beep out and
get in the car you thought it was now
he's cleaning himself like nothing
happened but she knows when people are
lying like as soon as Prince is playing
pulled over he called me and he goes
Prince got about a week left I swear to
my mother's grave really yeah he sees it
like one time we went to do with the
Artie Lange show and when we left he
goes I don't know what the [ __ ] he's
getting these high or yeah no he's not
he's been sober fee but this is no way
that's so long yeah house so it was
funny yesterday he calls me out of the
blue and I'm with mercy and with my
daughter watching the news
and I pick up the phone when what's up
joining us leave these [ __ ] idiots
Demi Lovato is going through a rough
time at the hospital
she'll deed on the 24th she's not going
through a rough time she's dope sick
you've got [ __ ]
these are you with the [ __ ] newspaper
yeah he just picks up [ __ ] he'll tell me
little things that I don't see you know
you think you're like a man of the world
but man he always picks [ __ ] off I
killed Tommy this guy seeing pills yeah
this guy smells like heroin
I gotta you know I could smell it I
still smell that [ __ ] it's like an
airport dog oh my god he's amazing but
he'll tell me when people I can't tell I
can't tell people I told people don't
cope ya did it for 30 [ __ ] years but
I can't tell when somebody's doing like
a pill or something like that yeah yeah
huh who gives a [ __ ] where we're at Alan
coke I was blown away when I moved here
how much coke was in LA Oh guys I'm sure
there was some way in Boston but I
didn't hang around those people and
everyone does Gucci cocaine I was the
first party I went to here was something
I worked with that's crazy and it was it
wasn't on the table wasn't anything like
Hollywood parties that you hear about it
was just today we're taking key bumps is
what they call they had like right in
front of you they went into another room
but they said that what they were gonna
do and and and that's I got here
everyone talking about I've never that's
one of the few things I apparently
haven't done but uh they they'd talked
very openly about here and that's one
that I don't hear about is heroin I hear
pills now I know that's a huge thing
across America because their communities
drugs are a community okay like I'd sit
here for years and tell you I was a
junkie for 27 years I think in 27 years
three people approached me for heroin
maybe two people approached me for meth
yeah because it's a community you know
when I first moved here and Josh wolf
Italian like let me talk to Josh tell
the tale about the heroin lesbians in
the bill okay they were [ __ ] ha I
mean torture the ones father invented
something yeah so they got checks at
that time we lived in the building I
slept on Josh's couch he had but nine
kids yeah [ __ ] wife you were baby
forever
then the building was crazy
we had a jewel upstairs that thought he
was black
and he called himself white lightning
and he sold weed then there was a
Mexican gang the third floor that sold
coke then there was a publicist then
there was a chick that had the best tits
you ever seen your life but she had no
chin but she still sucked a tremendous
dick he would cope that he went over
there and knocked on the door but there
was this then there was a chick that was
and like porn actress that was
phenomenal
she's from Canada I just saw her in the
movie with Eric Roberts recently [ __ ]
phenomenal lived in that building yeah
but there were these two chicks that
lived in that building that were
beautiful 25 you know I never hit you
know Kai I ain't know I didn't know the
whole story Josh do the whole story
Josh would talk to him josh is
good-looking they would talk to Josh
Josh would fill me in they wouldn't even
take showers Josh says that body order
because they were heroin people that
what's your clogs fill up you don't want
to sweat because you don't want to sweat
the heroin out so when you eat chocolate
it activates the heroin together I mean
good lord when then I got to meet them
and when they were telling me they
always wore sunglasses they didn't work
and they would just shoot heroin all day
but they were none they were not a
little bit they were both skinny they
were puking yeah well if that's when I
learned that this commute make like any
they had 30 friends that would come over
they were all on there yeah yeah yeah
like you know to their own something who
does mess no okay they so 20 there are
thousand kilos a method years he's gotta
be [ __ ] doing it yeah I don't do it
now I'm not running in a meth crowd I
don't yeah it's so weird like who runs
in these crowds so that's why they're
little good like pills community yeah I
know a couple P I have two friends that
do massive amounts of blow and they eat
massive amounts of pills every once in a
while the guy calls but he goes Joey
you're a comic do you know anybody and I
know a few people I'll get him a hundred
of this or a hundred of that but the
community and the price is like absurd
yeah like absurd like I get 60 [ __ ]
xanax is what do you call those anxiety
1.2 pills they last me a year
I think again [ __ ] $14 yet you know
my buddies pay for pills like $13 a
[ __ ] pill that's crazy it's like one
of those axes that thing that that
[ __ ] dude was even that we were
talking about them rush limbaugh of
oxycontin or things of $50 a piece I
heard yeah I don't know I never knew I
knew one person who did actually condom
no I can't get off that [ __ ] either yeah
that's great it's uh it's scary but but
do you agree do you think that coke is
maybe a bigger circle out here like I
think I think I think there's you walked
outside if you talk to people about coke
when I was growing up it was girl you do
coke and now it's like oh come on you
watch you watching articles at all yeah
lovely watch it oh yeah do you see the
part when they he thought he was gonna
get fired and then he quit but when the
guy called the Magnus will make this
[ __ ] then go away and they talked to
him and they said some that they were
370 metric tons of cocaine a ton is
2,000 [ __ ] pounds the United States
alone in the early eighties was doing
400 tons a year of cocaine good lord
somebody was doing it yeah yeah somebody
was funny he's only where'd you grow up
Lee right outside of Boston okay and I'm
sure they had it but I was I was a dork
and I I mean I saw weed and stuff but I
even talking to people like I would hurt
people while doing ecstasy I heard about
that more than that but I didn't hear
anyone doing the heroin or meth or when
you grew up where you grew up in
Virginia was it a drunk neighborhood I
mean will you expose to it
no you'd see some stuff that was weed
people smoking weed I think I saw coke
like two or three times randomly ecstasy
wasn't around so I never even heard of
that there were guys that did acid a
bunch of guys that ended up following
the Grateful Dead they did a lot of acid
my first my first day of college
somebody put acid in my beer slipped it
right in the beer yeah what did you
think no it was the second day first day
we were all drinking in the dorms and we
were drinking vodka and the second night
we were drinking and the
guys came down and they the night before
it's a saw a Grateful Dead poster on my
dorm room and they're like hey man hey
you want to take some acid with us
tomorrow I was like nah I'm good man I'm
just gonna drink since are you sure I'm
like now I'm good I'm good
so then they called me down to the room
I mean this other guy they're like come
on down we're gonna drink some beers and
they gave me a beer Miller Miller
Genuine Draft I think it was and the top
wasn't on it but I wouldn't think
anything no here you go let's have some
beer so drank and drank and then I
started feeling like something's a
little something's a little wrong here
you know something's something's going
on and then I chugged the beer because
we were playing some drinking game and I
threw up and there was a little bit of
blood and I was like with that what is
this you know I got a little nervous and
I I decided I'm gonna go to the doctor
I'm gonna go to the doctor and these
guys drove me there and then it was
until I got back because the doctor was
like what are you doing I got out and I
drink a lot of vodka
yesterday he goes I will take these
pills you'll be fine and I came back to
the dorm
and that's when somebody told me hey
those dudes put acid in your beer and
then I just was up all night and you
know just finally fell asleep at about
6:00 in the morning woke up around 10
a.m.
went down to grab the empty bottle of
vodka from two nights before knocked on
their door one guy's laying in bed the
other one is standing at the door I said
did you [ __ ] put acid in my beer he
goes yeah man he goes we thought you
thought it would cool you thought it
would be me and I hit him with the
bottle and gave him about eight stitches
in his chin blood started jumping out of
his you know and they're all bigger than
me and then the guy in bed started to
get up and I told him to stay in a bed
so he did and then didn't they came back
to school and I was pissed off at him
obviously cuz you know what the hell and
and they didn't get in any trouble in
the school they ended up turning
themselves in because they thought I was
gonna turn him in that turn crazy and
then the funny part the the ending of
this was I decided you know what I'm
gonna sue these dudes because they're
being [ __ ] and they're they're
flaunting it a little bit I've still
pissed off that they did it and I'm look
I'm 18 years old and I'm thinking you
know I wouldn't do that today but I'm
like I am 18 I'm gonna do this I sue
them I ended up suing them for 6 million
dollars
right now these guys don't have I hit
them with a lawsuit for six million
dollars they don't have any money and my
lawyer is my soccer coach when I was a
little kid right so we're talking about
we're gonna go to court with them and
everything and this was all happening
over the summer and and a day before
court my soccer coach pulled me in he
goes listen man they've made an offer
you know I'm thinkin I cool what's this
you know what he he said they've offered
$7,000
and I said 7,000 goes yeah yeah yeah but
I'll take my cut you'll get about five
grand and I go but you were suing for
six million he goes yeah but they don't
have it and if you get up on that stand
you gotta sit there in front of
everybody you got to talk about every
single thing you've ever done they're
gonna grill you your parents are gonna
hear anything you've done or your
perjure I said take the seven thousand
so it's [ __ ] crazy how you an attorney
could make you become like a [ __ ]
victim yes ed we live in us that's the
sad part of but he was right - it would
have been blood from a stone they didn't
have anything you know when I robbed
that jewelry store when I was 18 it was
the same day the guy made a smart move
why I disappeared the cops were looking
for me
the guy was little connected they told
him they solicit for your restaurant
what's he gonna do
pay your restitution I can go from front
of a judge and go why don't we make $10
a month yeah and you get $1 a month for
life by the time you get your money back
so he paid the cops to look the other
way he got the insurance in 30 days
there you go cuz if you get arrested
there you gotta get restitution the guy
was like yeah I didn't want to chase
these guys down the resident the funny
one other thing was they said when we
hit him with the lawsuit they said to
Maya my lawyer they said hey we're gonna
counter sue you because your client you
know hit our client in the chin with a
bottle and he got eight stitches in his
chin so we're gonna sue you right back
and my lawyer quickly said we have my
client was on acid
I mean he's not he's not responsible for
the [ __ ] he did quit thinking soccer
teacher yeah yeah exactly he was a good
soccer coach and a good lawyer so yeah
that all that was a crazy little intro
to college for sure you know what's so
crazy I was told
we that infected with situational my
ex-wife you know we have a really bad
act in a situation I have a 27 year old
home talked to and a couple weeks ago I
wrote a letter I was like you know I
wrote all the things how I [ __ ] up you
know and this time stagger you know
someday she's gonna raise her hand you
know but she can't she can't yeah
because she's gonna exposed herself to
even worse you know it's even worse for
her she's a pillar in our community you
know she said no all I do is open one
thing she could probably sink me but I
could sink her because those type of
people are very concerned about what
people think
do you follow yeah she came through one
time and she goes I'm changing the
baby's name because the friends I hang
out with are not really crazy about
Spanish last names
yeah she's part of that community in
Boulder that they're very avant-garde
and Shan want the kid to have a Spanish
last vein now you wrote the letter did
you send it no I live in I'm five no no
why not send it I wanted to come clean
with myself yeah what I wrote of
yourself yeah you know for a long time I
had anger I had this anger and I'm we
listened let's say it was 1995 was I
really ready to be a parent of 95 yeah
would you leave your kid with me in 95 I
don't think so
nothing I was a bad person yeah I just
wasn't ready
how old were you 32 yeah well was 32 the
116
yes mentally [ __ ] you know between
the drugs and the deaths and the [ __ ]
damage I had been through I was done you
know and I said a lot of things and I
made a lot of actions but I'm not stupid
you know this is one of those situations
where you did this and I did this she
could never really go write a book about
85 to what she saw in those six years
and then [ __ ] destroy people it would
destroy people she was right there with
me mm-hmm
you know why she would make me take piss
test for marijuana but she would break
into my house to steal weed
she's one of those type of yet the other
side so you'd never win with those type
of people like I would say to her I I
would get to my house and I could seen
the trail of wheat cuz I always had weed
in the bottom freezer in though and the
wettest day that's why we keep from
wasting Colorado the crisper the crisper
yeah we in there and there's what I was
dealing pounds she would go in there and
take weed then go to the probation
department they would test me for
marijuana
she that's the playing field she was
that yeah so is she what the that
playing field I took it for the playing
field I grew up with the [ __ ]
seek-and-destroy you know and I was
telling leave that well I did speak to a
couple years ago I apologized to her
because we went to court one last time
for contempt and we went up in front of
the judge that sentenced me and that by
this time I had this judge in my pocket
I was writing letters every month Tom
I'm trying I'm going back to school I
got my GED I'm turning into a comedian
I'm trying thank you for giving me a
chance thank you for sending me to
prison I mean I had this guy yeah I had
him just in case something happened
again he he had documentation yeah we
walk into the civil court and there he
is and I won that never forget on the
way out like I had they they told her if
you don't show up at the kid again it's
contempt the court will lock you up and
have a sheriff and I remember walking
out of there and that 200 yard walk was
the worst walking her life yeah 20 Greg
Garcia I said things that human bein
doesn't say you know I went way below
the belt in front of her husband like
did you ever tell him I put the carrots
in your [ __ ]
I mean oh yeah oh she even brought the
detective that arrested me there'll be a
character witness against me like he was
how he still involved in the drugs and
he's telling me to shut up alone when
you shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] you can't
arrest me I'm just talking out here this
is but this has nothing to do with you
and her face is red and then when they
walked out they were a husband and
couple team I said so many things to her
like I stuck it up her ass with the
carrot I call her Kathy carrots
how long did this court stuff go on for
it's so toxic went on from 91 to 95 it
ruined me Greg Garcia Wow with me
financially it ruined me because we were
friends we were friends doesn't have to
happen this way but I knew after the
third month of our separation thought I
was gonna have a hard time with that kid
something was gonna go down with this
kid that was her weapon yeah
to show me you know that was her weapon
to show me that she was the boss
so was weird when I got that car Jun
would you lie first of 1995 and I love
that bulb I knew I knew that my life was
gonna change I was never gonna be if I
was never gonna get invited to a first
communion or I do yeah you know you know
it was done and then I would come home I
booked the Taco Bell commercial I was
making a lot of money here that would go
home to meet her at that time since I
have left the state
I really have lost my rights to see her
so I would call him and say let me meet
with her on Wednesday and she would go
okay then she called me my gosh she's
too busy with girls cops she can't come
see you so that sounds good she took her
out of the country playing games she
moved to London for a few years it was
it was rough but now you get to do it
all what do you mean what would then you
know well now I got a second chance yeah
this is why I'm to the book with this
step I'm to the book with this Greg like
I told you had five lives a cat's got
nine lives before was telling you I was
a volunteer fireman for a while and that
mean the start that I was telling Libya
and that about the nineties you know
what that the success I have today in
common is because of the work I put in
the nineties yeah I heard you talking
about sleeping on buses trains and you
know it's it's so I'm you get to do it
all again and there's nobody that that
isn't gonna be a better parent in their
late 40s and 50s than they would have
been in their 20s and 30s I had kids my
20s and 30s and I know I was I'm a
better parent now for the youngest one
than I was for the you know for the
other ones cuz you know you're young
you're young - how old is your oldest 20
and what's your relationship it's great
it's great I I would say that's the
roughest relationship as he
was growing up because he knew what he
wanted to do he was you know he was more
you know bullheaded than the other ones
I guess and then I was also working a
ton you know I would work on my name is
Earl I'd worked 14 hours a day you know
every day and so I would see people I'd
see the family on the weekends cuz when
I left in the morning they were asleep
and when I got home at night they were
asleep how was that correct how does
that feel it's rough it's rough you know
now you know they all turned out great
my kids all turned out great so I'm not
gonna say like oh I wish I would have
done that because also that afforded us
opportunities for other things you know
it's a balance and I think you know a
lot of people you know in your 20s and
30s you know it's a balance and of just
like you know you've got to provide for
these people and at the same time you
want to be there you know so I tried
very hard on weekends to be there you
know and not work on the weekends and
then when I did have time off you know
they get stretches at times off you know
and TV during the hiatuses and I'd make
sure I was around for that but I know
for a fact you know I'm definitely
better dad now I got more time now to
but but you just you mature you know
you're less selfish you you know
everything and hoping it'll get old I
was not ready for beefing like I was not
ready for my marriage you know I told
Lee that I failed that marriage who
fails at marriage it's the simplest
thing in the world you [ __ ] and you talk
that's pretty much it haven't you [ __ ]
and you talk and you communicate when I
failed at divorce I don't know if it was
my Catholicism or me being me it really
got to me that I had failed that
something so simple with a human being
that's it hey listen you fail at [ __ ]
rock climbing that's one thing yeah you
come and you take a bronze and skiing in
the Olympics that's another thing us
failing as human beings that's absurd to
me yeah but you also have the added you
know stuff of you're talking about
having to deal with another person you
know I mean you're rock climbing there's
just a rock you know you got a to fail
at a marriage you know it
a two-way street I mean you know there's
a lot going on that I wouldn't beat
yourself up too much about that don't
there is Greg because no matter what
happens drop the arguing or whatever
there's got to be a point before before
you uh go to court but I could turn it
you know Greg can I don't because I'm
yeah seven years here we we dated before
that that's ten we need this
yeah you think you'll be able to figure
it out that really Greg yeah I mean all
this what the [ __ ]
you drop the half a mil that you didn't
have I dropped two hundred grand but I
didn't have plus another hundred and
credit cards I didn't have for what what
did we both [ __ ] him we lost a hundred
thousand dollars when that friends no
more she doesn't have a dad she has a
stepdad who did a great job I can't take
nothing away from but that always comes
back to bite you in the ears yeah but
everybody wants to win it's about ego
it's about ego so I put it in simplest
terms as I can you ready she got a life
and I got a lot I got to become my comic
and she got to get away from me and
raise her daughter where she want it's
just like man I'm fired a life for a
life yeah that's it it's man on vine a
life for a life
this times I said hang on Jesus Christ
you know she was there the night I
robbed those dudes with divine
millimeter you know she could choose the
one of the talk show today mm-hmm and
tell three hours of stories but I got
story yeah you got stories too I guess I
and you got more places to tell them so
oh yeah and I've told half of them and I
got a forgery story that that [ __ ] don't
go away
yeah and I'm saying I got a forgery
story that I could get father's behind
me as support insane like fathers groups
this father's groups that I just had too
much pride to contact up at one point
that you contact them and they groups
and they tell you these are all I have a
friend I can't say I grew up with him
another guy and all from the fifth grade
he married a chick that our flat father
had so much money
Thank You shant Pickett
I should the wife change and they may
have to change the name he hasn't seen
his kids says she was straight his
vanished vanished huh
went to court beat him in court for sole
custody
he got visitation she turned it around
she turned to rehab stint around for
pain medication he had broken like a leg
and got hooked on pain medication I like
in 2001 and she turned it into this
[ __ ] and I know this guy this guy's
had the same job all his life he's one
of those duddy dudes I just grew up with
him
he's never no contact no nothing hmm
yeah uh you know III definitely if I
would have if I would have married any
number of girls that I dated instead of
my wife I don't think you know wouldn't
it last it you know it's luck there to
you know finding the right person but
you know growing up there wasn't a lot
of divorce
growing up work oh no and then I moved
out here I moved to my neighborhood
price 16 years ago and I met about say I
met like 10 to 12 couples 11 of them
divorced at this point and it's crazy
for crazy to me and I said to my mother
I was saying that to her and I was like
yeah 11 she goes that's because that's
because you that's because they have
money and I said I don't know about that
people you know get divorce she goes no
it's because they can afford she goes
you think I would have stayed with your
father we could have afforded two houses
she owes you think for a second if I
thought I could get my own house I would
have been and I thought yeah yeah god I
could see that I could see that but it
also reminds me of something that
somebody said once they last this old
couple they said how did you stay
married what was your secret how did you
stay married for 50 years he said well
we didn't get divorced
that's pretty much it we kept fighting
but you know we just stayed I would I
have good bad days with my wife yeah
but I couldn't imagine a life without my
wife at this point oh no no absolutely
yes she got like you that worked 14-hour
days she covered the spread Oh
most wives are like oh I've done any of
that you know you end up you know she's
got a care
the load for all that stuff and I think
you're also in the thick of it with a
with it with a kindergartener I mean we
the most we ever fought was when the
kids were little when we're stressing
about the kid and and we're arguing over
what's the best way to deal with the kid
and whatever and then I noticed as you
know as the kids got older and we stayed
married longer you kind of mellow you
mellow out with that stuff and and it
gets to the point now where like if
somebody raises their voice or it starts
to get mad it's almost like the other
person's like oh [ __ ] this is that
important to you no no that's good
you got it your way we don't need to
fight I grew up in a house bro when I
was yelling and screaming it drove me
crazy I hate walking into a house where
there's yelling you have to reminds me
of my house oh no I hate that [ __ ]
so I always swore you know thinking over
the years I don't like driving my house
like I don't even want to see a [ __ ]
beer bottle in my house like I like
coasters and [ __ ]
yeah those [ __ ] huh I always think
that your house should be your sanctuary
you know like I go home for peace like
when I was married the year before I got
separated I would go home to hate myself
like we didn't really it was uh it was
uh it was a home without a heart have
you ever lived at home without heart
I have been lucky not to but I can
imagine it sucks I looked into homes a
lot hearts before my mother died the
home didn't have a heart she was like
two people who live together me and my
mother yeah then when I got sick she
became mom again but it was too late she
died two months later uh-huh and then
when I got married I lived in a home the
last year was a [ __ ] horror show I
basically went home at 6:00 ate dinner
kissed a baby and I was a doorman at a
comedy club but it was like I didn't
want to be home
that's a horrible yeah now that's rough
when you have a child that you don't
want to be home and I've worked with
guys that don't want to go home and it's
just like it kills me yeah those guys
those type of people [ __ ] killed yeah
so a they're either in charge and
they're keeping everybody there because
they want a good don't go home or you
see them just stay and after it's over
and like they're just staying in their
office and I don't get that man that's
that's that's rough that is rough
can't imagine I've had 50,000 arguments
with agents over the years about this
[ __ ] that we know and how it works for
me and what doesn't work for me
the every other week works for me and
time off like in June December works for
me
you know these guys that go out a lot
with kids I don't see it yeah you have
to be home yeah you have to be home I
love doing stand-up and making money we
all do especially got because they got
to go on the weekends yeah and that's
when the kids are home I mean there's
one thing if they can get out during the
week or something because you know kids
are busy a lot of the time but yeah then
those weekends are important they got
the games they got whatever else other
thing I do is I don't I don't talk about
I never bring any work home with me
either I think that's that's a key
sometimes too I don't ask you like dad
was it cool working with this guy dad
how was it working with this chick
that's not what your house is about no
no I mean once in a blue moon I mean my
oldest son he's interested in
entertainment business so he'll ask more
questions but like I won't come home and
talk about work at all like we've just
finished shooting that the season two of
the guest book my wife doesn't know what
it's about nothing and she'll sit down
and watch them all and that'll be great
cuz I'll have a fresh audience but I
don't I don't come home and talk about
work at all there's too many other
things going with three kids there's
other stuff going on they don't need to
hear about it nor do they they don't
really care too much no what's your
typical year look like now well now it's
been pretty it's been pretty relaxed now
because with this new show we do ten
episodes at a time I write all ten of
them myself so I just take my time to
get those done and then we shoot them
for ten weeks and then we edit them for
you know about two months it takes the
house it take you to write the ten
episodes usually it depends on the
episode but usually what I'll do is I'll
have a pretty good idea I'll let some
but something just like kind of marinate
in my mind a little bit I'll be thinking
about it I'm not even writing stuff down
but I'm just thinking about it for a
while then I'll sit down I can usually
write a script in a day but I sit down
at 6:30 in the morning and I don't get
up out of that chair except to go grab
something to eat sometimes my wife comes
in back at houses walk around a little
bit
I won't get out of that chair until four
in the morning and just right and I'll
just force myself to just keep going and
going and going and going and by the end
of it I got a first draft and then next
couple days I'll kind of mess with it a
little bit and and play with a little
bit but it's that one day when I decide
I'm gonna write I just write it on the
calendar and that's it I just sit there
and I just refuse to get up until it's
done I could do to 2 hours of the showw
yeah cuz of my back I could do two hours
then force myself to get up and walk if
not I'll stay there all day yeah and
that's not bueno either for me cuz I
lose my [ __ ] mind
yeah those four walls and you're not
really on it but also you're not on it
on a deadline necessarily right I mean
cuz you're you're writing you're
collecting all your stuff but is
somebody saying to you it's god we got
to get it by here we got to have it then
that would kill me yeah that would kill
me because I'm not confident in my
writing so when I wake up the next day
and I look at it if I wrote two
paragraphs one paragraph always goes
yeah what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] here you know
so one paragraph always go so I'm
basically writing a little every day but
I'm also cleaning up yesterday's garbage
yeah well you gotta just write down
whatever and don't worry about it and
just get through it and then go right
for different things at once
when I wake up in the morning I have a
little book and I put my feelings that I
feel like [ __ ] is what's going on I
can't believe I did this
I'm the read those edibles again you
know you know just spill whatever is on
my mind yeah and then I have a notebook
that I write to my daughter every couple
days so what's going on in my life so if
I die I wanted to know what the [ __ ] I
was thinking yeah at that time period
that's very important for children so
there's never any doubts when my mother
died left a lot of doubts in my life my
daughter have doubts this is what God
Bible and I'll wrap them up and rubber
bands and leave it in the [ __ ] safety
deposit box or something
yeah after mercy then the iPad I haven't
chokes now I really like the iPad that
my wife got me there's a writing up on
there and I have jokes in there I have
the book did I just have individual
stories yeah like this one I'm writing
is about martial arts in America today
when I joined martial arts there was a
black dude that walked around with a
Ginsu wooden sword and if you giggle
this [ __ ] he hit you with the [ __ ]
sword and you gotta do push-ups and you
had to bring your karate teacher your
report card if you didn't get good
grades you [ __ ] you weren't allowed
to go in and do jumping jacks and
sit-ups but well you weren't allowed to
learn he would make you sit there and do
[ __ ] homework with your uniform on
like a [ __ ] bunch you know you can't
do that today yeah I take my daughter to
martial arts and I had to tell the
teacher if you yo tell her the [ __ ]
knock off tell them to start doing
somersaults tell them to stand at
attention don't be scared
yell at my [ __ ] kid yeah that's why
we're here yeah that's why we're here
for discipline yeah then look at me
don't look at me look at him he's the
[ __ ] boss for the out yeah you know
then I got a little pissed last week for
the first time I got to be honest with
you guys she came home with a medal
oh my god what the [ __ ] is the metaphor
and she told me that there was a race
but she raised herself so they gave her
a [ __ ] medal so yesterday at karate
she couldn't do the punch combination
she started crying when we get home
she'd always get out of a car until she
won a race and then she'd say I went I
went I went you know I wanted to teach
how to [ __ ] lose sometimes it's not
all when I play a card game whether
she's [ __ ] good at it she beats me
every time it hasn't even beat her I
actually have a sheet the beater and she
gets pissed when I'm being a bad gotta
show her yeah you have to show you they
gotta lose to get that feeling in their
stomach so they want to win the next
time you know I was taking her to
jujitsu but there was one guy and there
was no other kids and she was learning
great stuff but I wanted to see what her
reaction would be the kids her age you
know even if I hire you to come over and
beat Lee up you're not gonna be Leah you
know if I give you 200 a day to come
home and crime Lee you know that Lee Cho
Kim is [ __ ] because the day you
bitch-slap Lee he's gonna come tell me
you [ __ ] slap time without seeing you
on you today
yeah no I don't give you an extra yard
for punch
the [ __ ] stomach that's the school I
come from I want to see him in his worst
so when life [ __ ] really you know
when I went to karate
one day they kicked me in the stomach so
hard that they knocked the air out I
mean when you're a kid and you get the
oxygen left Ali it's a scripted oh yeah
you think you're dying I'm never telling
my mom I'm not going back and my mom
goes listen you either get back in there
right now while I'm punching the stomach
50 [ __ ] times
you won't even you won't get oxygen that
[ __ ] stomach for 20 [ __ ] years you
understand me and she made me go back
and today's society your parents aren't
allowed to do that don't call the cops
yeah if a parent sees you do that yeah
yeah yeah my body was telling me a story
about he just put his hands on some kids
shoulders because the kid was acting
crazy at the park and he said oh come on
buddy and just they went nuts on don't
you touch my kid bah bah bah bah bah my
kids fine but you know I don't and just
you know just just trying to move him
you know how about I tell my wife
because my wife is part of the white
generation that she cares I tell my wife
all the time mind your [ __ ] business
my three years ago
she went to a park in Thousand Oaks or
something for one of those [ __ ]
things and there was almost a child
abduction they ever tell you about then
I told you I told the story alright and
how they do it is they cause a commotion
and then you go run over when your kid
makes things feel your kid but I told my
wife don't you ever run turn your back
on that my wife knows the rule now yeah
don't ever turn your back on mercy
outside listen I don't give a [ __ ] I had
to tell my wife about a month ago at a
pool time okay give me a favor
I'm not hitting soldier you know I love
you and respect you I make the cash in
this house put that [ __ ] phone away
watch your kid don't turn it into the
Studio City parents I've seen [ __ ] in
this vicinity here yeah that'll make you
[ __ ] curdle I've seen people bring
their kids to swim class that'll allow
you know like mommy and me and they put
the nanny in the pool with that kid yeah
Nell they sit there and [ __ ] text and
do whatever the [ __ ] they do parents
filled with tattoos is [ __ ] what do you
think this kid's gonna grow up to be
what are his chances
yeah so with me I'm old school you know
what man III did some bad things rolling
up
badbrakes but I got myself out of it
because of what I learned there's a
young man what was it still to me by my
mother and I look around all those
lessons I remembered oh oh sure I know
my mother going you you don't get back
in that karate school it's not gonna be
good for you in the Casa yeah
cuz it'll be a long day for you the cars
I'm gonna beat you to it [ __ ] enough
I used to get spanked all the time I get
hit with this metal ruler and there was
no doubt that I deserved every single
one I got and it made me think twice
about doing some other stupid [ __ ] it
was what's the way to go here he is
[ __ ] crazy it was the way to go I
miss chains but I kinda got pissed at
that right this Friday and they're doing
two buddies are getting married yeah at
the camp I gotta go witness two buddies
get married you know that shit's cute I
like it but there's a lot of [ __ ] that's
going on playing the kid world at
[ __ ] distance doesn't cook with me
Greg Garcia yeah
just you're not doing nothing good for
this kid he's not doing them any [ __ ]
favors no I trust me especially my
younger one I see these other little
kids he runs around with and they run
roughshod over their parents and it's
just like what the [ __ ] man are you
gonna be talked to like that it's like
kids just saying no uh-huh
ain't doing it you know and it's like
well that freaked me out of the kid
because my parents weren't okay let's
paint a few times but that was the
extent of it but when I saw kids talk
back to their parents and like yell at
their parents oh [ __ ] I almost died yeah
first time like first time I saw like a
white kid my neighborhood white kids
with notorious for you I'm not that I'm
not knowing it I saw that [ __ ] I was
like oh that's [ __ ] stitches in my
house that's automatic [ __ ] stitches
that talking back yeah my mom used to
give me this backhand it was closed up I
woke up just a backhand oh yeah if I
said something wrong some time to time
it was like effortless you just give me
like a BAM my lip would bleed [ __ ] a
little bit like I got a thousand those
yeah I remember getting the beat once at
a restaurant and you know my mom used to
kill the Cuban doctor we had in the days
the Cuban doctor would make a house call
but
mom was in with him so much he goes
there's no reason for me to come back
here's the syringe and here's some
penicillin if he gets sick just give him
a shot yourself yeah bro my mom was shot
happy with that [ __ ] thing everything
cuz I was a sickly [ __ ] kid every
time you sneeze oh come in and she would
get me like Anna what sex when they hold
you headlock yeah cuz I would go it's
gonna hurt it's gonna hurt she would get
me in the guillotine and [ __ ] stab me
with the needle and I'd toughen up so
I'd have a bruise halfway down you know
many blood clots I had all these people
that died from blood clots go [ __ ] you
fell I had something blood clot there
was a time she gave me I couldn't walk
for four [ __ ] days because I would
fight her I will fight the madness
doctor called Orlando no value that was
a coke beat so he would come over to the
house he'd take my temperature they go
house on Tony oh we gonna have to give
you a shot and I go alright let me think
about it he loved it cuz he's gone
little have a couple drinks yeah do a
couple bumps of coke and [ __ ] and then
he come back in and give me a shot I
didn't know he was a cokehead till I got
old the years later you come and join
gonna give me a shot and then we're like
after my mother died he was my family
doctor I went to him for years I don't
know right yeah so I cut a deal with him
I would give him a boy we can begin with
prescriptions for steroids with my
friends say all my friends had a handle
on winstrol and I would just bring him
an 8-ball and the last time I saw him
was a discotheque in New York and he
came up to me I'm like 19 he's like 50
he's like well Antonio get Danny back
uh-huh that means what do you got for
your head yeah I mean either
aspirins when he just walked away from
me and that's it and about two years ago
I heard he's still alive in Miami they
stripped his license yeah because he had
two kids that were my age they're the
80s they stole all his prescription pad
okay I had [ __ ] him were giving out
valiums and [ __ ] xanax it's a long
time he does all that [ __ ] in the kid
screw him over the kid screwed him over
dog there was a time in this country
that you could go to school you gotta go
to doctors know that doctor charge you
25 for a note yeah
did you know that don't you just go at
night you could you can stay at the
school for a week give me the wrong
number
and then just go to a doctor said I was
ready the doctors know what's wrong with
you
with 25 hours yeah and they give you the
22 give you a doctor's no you go with
the school give the back with no it's
over you can't do that double huh huh
where are you getting $25 don't worry
about it oh yeah he's so drunk you steal
from your dad somebody's got such 45
hours what else happen man
so what do you do not talk Toby you just
editing just editing and then this show
should come on in October and I gotta
figure out what's next is actually you
know just thinking about some ideas and
you know that's at my chili I did not
know about the Jimmy Buffett tape oh
yeah closed in about four months it did
not do as as good as they expected but
it's gonna go on a national tour in 2019
and they think that's where they're
really gonna get the audience's the New
York audiences the theater critics they
were not ready for a Jimmy Buffett
musical you know and you really need
those really good reviews to get people
to that with Jimmy Buffett ever show up
was oh yeah yeah yeah he well he would
come he would come on special occasions
and play at the end of the show and
stuff and he was great he was he was a
cool guy I loved working with him and
everything ended up hanging out with him
down in the keys and flying in a plane
with him where he's flying the damn
plane and it was it was a lot of fun 70
or 71 one of the two and still play
shows goes out there with just shorts
and a t-shirt and no shoes and Toby he
still gets 10,000 people to show Oh he
he sells oh yeah yeah yeah he'll sell
out major major stadiums yeah yeah yeah
absolutely
and that's why they're gonna
strategically what they do is now that
it will the show will tour and it'll go
to all those cities where he sells out
you know and so once we get out of New
York I think it's gonna do pretty well
because it did great in La Jolla in New
Orleans Houston and Chicago and went to
all those places and sold out the whole
time did great then went the Broadway
they booked a theater that I think was
too big
17 seat the 1,700 seat theater and you
know you got to sell those seats to keep
the lights on in those places are they
gonna put another show in what the
you read the bill come on I gotta go
take a quick leak yeah detain them do
you write this this probably a plan yeah
so we wrote the we wrote the story for
it so basically you take Jimmy they tell
you look here's Jimmy Buffett's music we
want to we want to sing all these songs
in the show you guys got to come up with
I wrote it with this guy named Mike
O'Malley you guys have to come up with a
story that it makes sense to hit these
you know to hit these songs along the
way so you got to sit down and listen to
the songs and be like all right well
what are we gonna do here so you listen
to a song and then maybe you think I'll
create a character that's in that song
so it'll make sense when they're you
know when they're singing that song so
you kind of create the characters listen
to songs then you start to figure out a
story and and and see how it all weave
together so it was a big math project
really I think cuz I went I was lucky I
went to a lot of theater as a kid I got
to go Broadway but it's very differently
because you just said you wrote you
write sitcom pilot sitcom scripts in a
day 24 hours how long does it take like
this was ridiculous because I mean I
don't know how long it took from just
like sitting down and writing but the
process would take it took four years
Wow it took four years because all other
people like the producers and the
director they're working on other things
so like you'll turn in a script you
won't hear anything for six months and
then it just keeps changing and changing
and changing like you know you do
you do so many performances of it and so
many rehearsals that they just want to
keep changing and changing and changing
so it takes forever have you ever
written a play but like previously no no
no this is the first time I didn't even
I didn't go seek this out I was sitting
in my house one day and actor writer
Mike O'Malley called me up and said hey
you want to write a musical and I was
like what the [ __ ] are you talking about
a musical and he's like yeah man he goes
we got it's Jimmy Buffett's music and we
got all the producers and the money and
everything's there and all we have to do
is come up with a story and knowing that
my oldest son is wanting to be in
theater and wanting to work with Michael
malli again I was like let's just yeah
why not and how and I thought at the
time what's gonna take a month to month
we'll write this script we'll be done
with it and then four years later that's
how long it took because of all the
stuff but and I turned out that Buffett
was a fan of my name is Earl and that's
why when my name came up he was like
yeah yeah yeah get him get him
and and so it was interesting it's a
different it's a different world because
I'm used to being in charge which is
nice you know when you have a vision
that you can just go do and make sure
that you get it you know the way you
want it you can direct it yourself and
whatever but that wasn't the case with
this you know I was like I was the I was
the writer and the director was in
charge and so that was a rough
transition for me to all of a sudden sit
there and watch him give the notes to
the actors and not necess
but I couldn't give my notes directly to
the actors so I'd have to give him my
notes about like hey this would be funny
or if this person said it like this and
he'd be like oh okay
and then he I'd watch him go give the
note but he wouldn't give the note all
the way right so he wouldn't really give
the note so you're just sitting there
going crazy and then you got to give the
note again and again and it was a it was
a it was an interesting process that's
for sure
was that your first shot at theatre yeah
my first and last I'll never do it again
it's so competitive in New York
yeah that's why people go to New York oh
absolutely just to go to [ __ ] theater
half of them get one ticket which they
[ __ ] bang you up oh how much was the
tickets for Buffy they were anyway I
mean I think they started to go lower
and lower but I think you could get in
there for about 80 bucks and then if you
want to sit in like the best seats it's
like $250 you know and they're trying to
sell 1,700 seats how many shows a week
eight eight shows a week so what was
happening with that show people you
gotta get it yeah week a week 13 14 G's
a week you gotta pull it and what was
happened on the weekends they were they
were doing really well but then you know
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday you know it
wasn't it was you know they weren't
filling the place up and I had to they
had to shut it down when did
Margaritaville come 77 imagine that so
77 I was about 13 yeah and I would smoke
pot and I would go to the shitty [ __ ]
nine around tumbly and it was horrible
horrible it's not there and nobody
remembers it's like a ghost like nobody
it was even on wheels this diner they
used to have those jukeboxes you know
yeah
seat 10 yeah and we would listen to
Margaritaville and we would smoke pot
and go in there when the waitress had
kind of a good laugh in the face and
then she would say I'll come back when
grow up that type of [ __ ] yeah we'd all
drive to the beach and listen to Jimmy
Buffett that was the craziest part
because um you know my friends back
Virginia they're all big Jimmy Buffett
fans and my wife is a big Jimmy Buffett
fan and so they came to the shows I flew
everybody down in New Orleans and they
met you know Buffett and everything that
was the best part of the whole thing
like I don't know it works it doesn't
work it doesn't matter to me I just you
know it was it was a whole experience
and to be able to live that with the
people that you would listen to that
music with and all of a sudden they're
just like this is crazy I'd be in my
office writing working on stuff and I
changed some of the lyrics to make sense
for the story I had to change some of
the lyrics and my wife would come in and
she'd be like what are you doing I'm
like I'm changing the lyrics to changes
in latitude and she's like this is crazy
this is insane so it was a trip
it was definitely I'm glad I did it not
gonna do it again but I'm glad I did it
well it's so funny when you came in let
me give a shout out some ya know Cassius
Morris congratulations on your hundredth
episode one by one podcast always there
Brandi Lynn I love you Dakota UTEP
vineet Oaks Tom bets sin queer and
killing them over there in Europe man
you seen his pictures oh my god in Jesus
Christ and my man Wayne woods don't
forget next Thursday
Casey improv [ __ ] Thursday Friday
Saturday I'm going up against Rogan on
Friday so I won't see nobody there but
I'll see you [ __ ] Thursday and
Saturday and then at the end of the
month I'm in Huntsville Alabama and one
shop and then I got on a [ __ ]
Nashville for four shows so if he in the
area stop in and say hello you know it's
funny I was at a pitch meeting and
people always you know what this is a
cross between masters of the universe of
The Sopranos people and I was in that
going nobody ever says this is a show
about this and [ __ ] raisin hope or
this is a show of this and my name is
zero because nobody does what you do bro
yeah those shows both had and they both
had pretty specific you know one guy in
what was one one guy got a serial serial
killer pregnant and took her and took
the baby and then yeah the other guy had
to list and everything this was pretty
specific pretty specific story
my name is earl caught me when you had
the episode of Leguizamo that's all I
heard that was a ribbon you had Josh
wolf was hilarious running
yeah the shearling [ __ ] running around
that field like this [ __ ] crazy
but just I was telling Leone I can't
find my name is Earl Hulu boom release
cuz it was on and I used to watch the I
used to download them back they won't
let you download cuz they're NBC yeah so
I would have to [ __ ] watch him in
hotel rooms and after you came on last
time I go let me watch this in the
beginning first of all the people you
got on that show
we got some good we got some good guest
stars oh my god number two just he was
great he's gray oh yeah he's great he's
great and I dunno I always had a crush
on Jaime Pressly if you don't have a
janitor depressed yeah what's wrong with
you exactly I haven't seen I see a UFC
fights she no that's right fights with
Joanne yeah yeah I'd be sittin like ten
free from when I go look at her she's a
[ __ ] he loved those things yeah you
know one night I'm thinking this chick
might take her shoes off and go after
God why she was into it yeah she was
decadent she got pregnant yeah see
anymore she got pregnant and then she
just had twins she had more kids she's
on that show Mom on CBS yeah she's on
there I know we talked about it last
time but we had Burt Reynolds on My Name
Is Earl and when he was there he signed
I had a Smokey and the Bandit Trans Am
you know Blackwood the gold eagle you
have the car and not no no no I have one
of them I have a car like that okay bye
you know when I was eight years old I
saw that car and I said I'm getting that
car one day so I have one like that not
one that was in a movie but one exactly
like it and so he he I drove it to set
and he signed it by the stick shift and
he signs to Greg you're the real band at
Burt Reynolds right so I've had that for
15 years sitting in my garage it's all
careful took it to work about a month
ago guy said hey man I'm gonna get this
detail for you I'm gonna take care of
the whole thing I said look look look
look look look
that's a signature from Burt Reynolds
tell the guy don't touch that he goes no
I got it I got I gotta go I got it back
at the end of the day it's barely there
the guide
just scrubbed and looked like he
scrubbed and scrubbed and scrubbed and
tried to get it off and so I'm I'm
pissed right and I never get mad and I'm
just like pissed because I've taken care
of this thing for 15 years I go to the
guy go man what the hell with that
what's going on
he goes I talked to the guy he said he
just put a towel over and he never
touched it and now I'm even more mad cuz
I'm like all right look look come on I
can't so I said that guy has to show up
tomorrow morning I got to talk to him so
he comes in and I said hey man come on
what's what's the deal you put a towel
on it and he goes he hung his head and
he goes look man I messed up I was on
the outside I had another guy on the
inside I looked in he was doing it I
forgot to tell him I screwed up and then
I was like I then I was like fine
like I wasn't mad anymore cuz I was like
I that's all I did that's fine people I
[ __ ] up people [ __ ] up what are you
gonna do I mean there's nothing I can do
about it I'm not gonna you know but now
at least I can sleep because that night
I couldn't sleep the towel
someone put a towel on it I was gonna
say don't may look I got some molds on
my back can I can I can I borrow your
magic towel present that's gonna make
that all go yeah
mixed up I see all right well I found
out he's gonna be I'm gonna track him
down cuz he's gonna be in town doing a
Tarantino movie the Brad Pitt and
Leonardo DiCaprio and stuff and Bert's
gonna be in that so I might have to
track him down get him to sign it again
I he was one guy that I expected
something completely different and I got
something completely different
yeah like he was dynamite yeah I
expected just to not talk to him or
whatever and at the table Reagan he came
right over started talking and I was
like okay and then in the mornings I you
know I'm an old I'm a old I like to get
up early
he said old man yeah so he'd see me and
walk over to me and we talked time to
time I'd be smoking a joint he goes what
are you doing nothing he would smell it
and he goes I haven't smoked that [ __ ]
in years and I would just put it up and
he would hit it a little bit then he
would walk away yeah [ __ ] he was just
yeah he was great on set he'd just sit
there and tell story after story on his
story
dog yeah that's that's the one-man show
I
have his one-man show by the way thank
ya I'm gonna give you okay
I have his one-man show I've never given
ever shown it to anybody he gave it to
me as a present
all right and that did he do it down in
Florida he did it in Vegas okay
[ __ ] call him about him the meeting
Jack Dempsey and I'm just ours but him
going to an audition what's the guy that
he went to London we're trying to figure
it out now what's his name ed Quinn was
on here an actor okay but he went to an
audition for count Kazan alright and the
guy that wasn't the hook in that movie
showed up with a gun and pulled the gun
on Kazan life he just has hours of those
yeah that when he got a call from Clint
Eastwood one day or Steve McQueen said
I'm picking you up we're going out to
Vegas and he goes are we gonna Vegas for
you just remember when we started the
director that fireless he died and I
always told mother no business [ __ ]
great let's go piss on his fighting area
then that he did the thing that nobody
ever did he brought down DeLuise it yeah
the long shot and that was like four
gallic me bro that's like watching Lucy
and Desi oh yeah you know they were old
and they started telling stories oh I
bet and it's if you like all that [ __ ]
you know yeah you like all that [ __ ]
yeah I couldn't stop asking them
questions let's I was I was speaking
about people bringing up your shows I
was just listening to bird crackers
podcast and he brought up the pilot to
yesteryear oh really because I didn't I
didn't I never watched the pilot but it
was I was thinking today like he was the
pilot no no he he said the audition for
but he said it was the best pilot he's
seen forsake um and I I was because
there's a lot of people like Seth
MacFarlane has Fox Lauren has NBC Chuck
Lorre has CBS you kind of have TBS like
I remember going home in high school and
would be the king of queens which isn't
you but then yes dear every day like
five days a week and I loved yesteryear
and I mean they put her and I put her
lon TBS yeah TBS bought a lot of my
shows after after after the fact yeah
yeah oh that's cool that Bert Kreischer
said that I'm a big fan of Burke right
yeah yeah yeah no you have some great
[ __ ] and I mean it's uh I got a lot in
like Breaking Bad
yeah the characters didn't sound siren
you didn't sell me yeah I've done that
again all the way he doesn't matter I've
done coke it wasn't real enough it was
it felt like something it was bought by
Peter seriously and I normally get a lot
of backlash was I didn't enjoy it I want
you know I I didn't understand the
hoopla sons of anarchy I
I'm not a big Kurt Sutter guy yeah but
he did a great job with sons and given
what he had yeah
it's a it's a Miami Vice music type [ __ ]
but yeah a little soap opera but his his
arc and everything was beautiful if you
watch that's why I watch My Name Is Earl
yeah I wanted to see what you had done
just to watch just to learn yeah you
know you don't want to watch a [ __ ] show
you want to watch me show yeah you're
the man
and just the art just what because I
have that that redeeming like I'm trying
to get redemption I'm sure to let it to
my ex-wife I apologize to the guy
kidnapped and then he didn't show up to
my shows yeah I'm in the same boat as
that guy if you could do that you could
do the reality version my name is Joey D
my name is Joey dick you know where is
he
Jason yeah he's in Texas rezaian
I think he's semi-retired he called it
Scientology's take a hike yeah yeah he's
not he's not part of that anymore he I
think he's semi-retired I was trying to
get him to come out and do a episode of
the guest book and he couldn't make it
work with his schedule because he had
just done this photography book and he
was uh he was doing a lot of book
signings for that but I hope to work
with him again soon you know I got to
get in touch with him because um we had
this uh remember that show Orange County
Choppers yeah all right so at the time
yeah with the moustache and his kids and
stuff yeah and I I just had a kid and I
was always up late at night with my kid
and I watched that and that showed
Deadliest Catch and I got into Orange
County Choppers and I thought it at one
point I go I want these guys to make a
My Name Is Earl
motorcycle you know and so I looked into
it we talked to them and we all decided
I we're gonna make this motorcycle and
we're gonna then auction it off for
charity so we went out we went to their
to their place and hung out and was in a
episode of their show and then they were
in episode of our show and they built
this big chopper the
thing I can't even reach the handlebars
on its his big giant chopper
so we auctioned off from make-a-wish
Foundation well I bought it because I
knew I was always gonna buy the thing so
I bought it and I gave it's my uncle who
lives in Virginia so he's had it for
about seven eight years or something and
it's it's a cool-looking bike but he was
riding at the other day and a bolt flew
out the front tire and he almost crashed
and he called me goes you got to take
this thing you got to get you got to
take this thing back out I don't want it
around here I'll ride it I don't want to
ride it and I said alright alright so I
actually got to get in touch with Jason
cuz I'm just gonna see if Jason wants
that thing because he likes motorcycles
I don't know what the hell I do with it
it'd have to be a piece of art just
sitting in a room somewhere so I'm gonna
hopefully get in touch with him soon and
hopefully he takes this thing off my
hands you know great you're a breath of
fresh air fresh air it really is an
honor always to work for you and just to
be around you because Hollywood such a
sack of [ __ ] it's rough man in it and
you were the only guys that's like the
anti Hollywood and you're really good at
what you do
oh thanks we had fun we had fun on those
episodes hazel I don't want to talk
about oh my god I have totally bought
yeah it was fun you know I signed like a
confidential highly agreement with
myself I love it because I can't wait
for people to do this yeah we'll bring
you back before the weird how your the
anti I went to you know I did a couple
of episodes of I'm dying up here yeah
yeah people nice people had great
thought but I went to the party and
there was a mistake great like I don't
do good at those I hate those things
and the other day like I hate those
things like I I have a lot of problems I
can't sit in a room with no windows
that's what happened to me on your set
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's what happened
I wanted to apologize to you for my
behavior
you don't worry when I go give blood if
I give blood in a room and no windows I
pass out yeah
if I give there's a window I could I
don't get anxiety at the Comedy Store my
anxiety when I walk up those stairs to
the original it's definitely fun
it's like I'm gonna be at home yeah but
as long as I know it there's a path
outside I'm okay like I could never be
one of those kids in that ty cave that
little ya dirty soccer coach they're
trying to take him down and [ __ ] him in
the ass cuz that's what he did better
face it why take a bunch of little
Chinese kids deep deep deep into a cave
he was gonna flop him and kill him don't
tell me I know a criminal when I see one
that guys they got a lot of explaining
to do that little dirty Filipino
whatever [ __ ] he was ty whatever he was
those people filthy [ __ ] animals
don't you go to Thailand to [ __ ] little
boys you [ __ ] I think that's the night
said with a God he do have a reputation
yeah yeah that's what then he was like
the leader he was like the [ __ ] sand
us oh my god the Philippines or Thai I'm
sorry Filipino people you know I love
you Catholics I think everyone was
Italian for that was doing that what are
you doing a [ __ ] capers I [ __ ]
people he hasn't even for that I think
that's it see he was planning on [ __ ]
up in the ass and you think I'm getting
you case closed ain't no [ __ ] Swami
but I know [ __ ] half a [ __ ] thank you
for all the shows and thank you for
everything thank you man oh it's a blast
to talk to you you ain't that Hollywood
but I want you to think about that today
on the drive home why else would that
coach take those kids into that [ __ ]
cave it wasn't planned I'm [ __ ] them
and killed him hi the last night people
in the cave was [ __ ] the Iceman
member the Iceman that killed a bunch of
people for the Mafia no but he took him
in a cave he had a cave in Pennsylvania
and he would take you in the cave film
it and let the rats get to you cut you
and let the rats either yet and then
film and then when you like let's say he
tells a particular story about a guy
that his daughter got raped by some he
told two stories where somebody's
daughter got raped and he went and took
the one guy I fed him to rats the other
guy he posted to a tree in Florida and
sliced his skin off with a razor blade
threw it into the water rubbed them down
with kosher salt nice and jewy and then
threw him into the ocean when he saw the
sharks he took the guys on skin to lure
the sharks you gotta read the book on
Lori
so he would slice inches off his belly
and throw it into the water to feed this
other sharks came and then once the guy
was nice and cut up just I'm tired of
men and they put it all on tape and he
get great would you give me 75 thousand
as your proof and you give the guy the
tape at the rat see the [ __ ] guy who
raped your daughter nothing good happens
in a cave nothing I'm telling you
nothing nobody gonna show me in a cave
mm-hmm and then they had to go on the
water and canals or he was gonna [ __ ]
those kids good he was kabob those
[ __ ] I love you [ __ ]
have a great weekend Greg Garcia thank
you don't forget anything by Greg Garcia
is [ __ ] gold yes the raising [ __ ] of
my name is arrow and not a guestbook
have a great weekend stay black we'll be
back Monday the six ready Iraq take this
[ __ ] Amelie